all right Miss Patty yes Miss Patty oh
where are you from originally where'd
you grow up originally up from Orlando
Florida I don't like to tell too many
people about that because Orlando is
such a crazy town with the alligators
and the crazy people what's crazy about
Orlando I mean it's just it's the South
you know and I'm so grateful to be out
of the South you're not even near the
coast yeah
you're not even near the coast no no
you're just embedded in the yes of the
humidity and you know that they they
look at addiction and mental health
totally different
I didn't get the help I needed so I came
out here how was it how's that well you
know I mean
they have the pill Mills out there and I
had a doctor
who wrote me any pill I wanted and had
me doing a lecture shock
down there
and um
it wasn't Titanic California that I
really received the help I had that I
needed I mean
you know
and so
um
I never want to see Florida again
all right let's go back to your family
tell me about your parents I have my my
dad passed away two and a half years ago
sorry and um I have my mom she's still
in Florida
um and that's it that's all the family I
had well I actually have an aunt and
uncle and cousins in Atlanta how would
you describe your childhood
um it was pretty good my cousins really
made my life a living hell growing up
um they teased me trying to make me
tough because they I think they they
knew I was gay and they were trying to
tough me up
um
but I had a pretty good childhood I
didn't start using drugs until I was 18.
and then I got booted out of the house
because I was gay
and then that's when
the party started
I went I ran all the way to my friend's
house who was a uh she was a
uh a secretary for a stockbroker
by day and then she ran drugs from
Florida to New York and uh
she introduced me to the drug life and
and the clubs and everything and and my
and she put me in college
I was probably
19 and she enrolled me in school
and um did she pay your tuition she did
and she she she bribed the person giving
the geds
so I would get my GED because I was
terrible at math I am terrible at math
and um she was a very dear friend of
mine and um
so I did that but I dropped out of
school and I I was a club promoter for
clubs in Orlando when I was that age and
I just that's when it was cute I was I
was it was cute to be a drug addict
and um I did I would do eight balls of
coke with 10 packs of ecstasy on the
weekend
and there was a time it all worked out I
would do that go to school go to my job
do it all over again you know it was
when I was in my 20s you know
and then um I thought I can't do this
anymore so I ran to the to like the
Backwoods of Florida
and I got my this job as a call center
agent
and even that job like I went in a
blackout and I went to from doing too
much Xanax and
and alcohol and I went to the job fair
and I woke up and my roommate was like
you got a job and I didn't even remember
and she's like you it starts at this
time
and so I went to the place and I didn't
even know what job I got and so I got in
there and I actually did that job for
quite a while and then I moved
um I was like I had to get out of this
small town of Orlando I gotta spread my
wings and then I moved to Atlanta
and Atlanta just ate me up and spit me
out
that's where the real drug use took over
and
um
I almost lost my life in Atlanta and
then I thought
um well let me go back to my hometown
because I won't I won't I will be okay
in my hometown and it just continued
and when I went back
um
I had a Moment of clarity
and my father was in the hospital and my
parents were constantly putting me in
these mental Wars
and um
they didn't know what to do with me and
then I I A friend of mine
I got a call that someone
paid for a rehab for me no I never knew
who
and so I went to the rehab and I came to
California I went to the rehab
and um that's where I proceeded to have
seven years
of really great sobriety like I really
had a wonderful life but the last year
my father I mean I mean I've traveled in
that seven years I traveled to New York
I became this drag queen
I um I performed for the 50th
anniversary of Stonewall
um we raised over sixty thousand dollars
for Gay Men's Health crisis I was part
of that
I had a talk show
um
it was called mugs and I have I still
have this really great
um
friendships with everybody
um I opened two LGBT sober livings that
were cash pay and I helped a lot of
people that are doing well now
but my in all that process and one of
them was in the middle of the pandemic
and um my father passed and I think that
was the start
of my downfall because
my father's house I went down to Florida
I arranged for my father's cremation and
then came back and instead of getting
help I just dove into that LGBT sober
living and I worked
I never really
got help
for it I did the very Spanish Latino
thing and just worked
and then
I worked I worked and then I started
doing these classes that my friend
introduced me to her and her husband at
the time called breath works
and um
so I would go every weekend
um and and um I thought well I need to
get out of this sober living I needed to
get out of this crew this this career
and I went and got an apartment that I
couldn't afford
and um so I went to the brothers and
then she was like
take this micro dose of mushrooms it'll
help you
uh go deeper into meditation
I was like Will Smith's son does that
why can't I and so micro dosing turned
it into a bag of mushrooms a week
and I still didn't consider myself
relapsed
and so for a year I microdose
and then I went back to my old drug of
choice of Adderall
and then at the end of the year I was
just smoking pot doing Adderall and
mushrooms and the problem with that is
it sent me into a very bad psychosis
so
um
at the end I had
um I went into a bad psychosis where I
thought the Illuminati were after me you
know that you need to think the
Illuminati or after you've seen shadow
people you know like it's either those
two things
and so
um I checked myself into
a psych ward
and then my sponsor came and got me and
took me back to Arizona but I was still
taking the Adderall and oh my God I
remember sitting in her backyard
and uh
like I took it and she she fed I was
very I was skinnier than I'm now and she
I Saturn sat in her backyard
and uh
I said don't call the cops don't be
alarmed
but I am NK Ultra
and I've been activated as an agent and
she just went uh-huh okay so I came back
I was out of my mind I came back
to uh California I've had my friend
uh Diego meet me at they in Vegas
because I knew I would never make the
plane I would never make anything and
that's the thing is I have these friends
from sobriety that are just supportive
so much like I needed someone to escort
me home
because I was so gone you know
and um he met me he took me back to uh
Los Angeles
and thank God because I as I mean I was
just having such psychosis I was out of
my mind and I went back and
it took them twice to stabilize me
and then when I went in I was lucky
enough to call in a favor because you
know I scholarshiped a lot of people in
my sober livings and so I've helped a
lot of people so this place helped me it
was called new Origins and they
scholarship me but it really wasn't a
right fit they were great but it wasn't
the right fit that's where the one our
one friend went that we did this
and um
so I came out here
and um my friend said what [__] what
are you doing in Redlands what are you
gonna do in Redlands there's no you know
what are you doing come out to L.A
so
um
I just been out here
and I still have remnants of the
psychosis every now and then but I did
damage I really did
um
I I still have uh the beginning ounce of
it
but you know I
I uh and then 19 days ago
I did this new drug called Kratom and
it's it's a synthetic opiates
and so that's why I had 19 days today
and so I'm just out here fighting for my
life because
I know
that if I don't get it together I'm
going to end up on Skid Row or dad
and I've worked in treatment I've worked
in
sober living I've run gay sober livings
they worked instruments I know
that if I do fat fentanyl it's my dad
I just know it and I know what's
Sentinel that so I and all of this you
hear me saying never once did I touch
Fentanyl
because I'd seen fentanyl when it's done
working in treatment I've seen the detox
and seeing the hook it has on people so
in all of this I tried to stay clear of
fentanyl that's why I went to The
Dispensary I did the mushrooms I knew
where it came from I never once did a
street drug because fentanyl is just
killing people which I never understood
you know when I was in my 20s
and in the 30s I knew my drug dealer you
know I personally knew him he delivered
my [__] if it wasn't good he would
deliver it again and now it's like
they're trying to kill their clients how
you were to think they'd want their
clientele
to be alive to buy more you know what I
mean as as adderall been your drug for
most of your life um Adderall mm-hmm
on Iran and pain pills yeah you know so
that's why I've been really careful
the pain pills can get in trouble yeah
huh the pain pills can get you in
trouble with them yeah so I've been I
did do some pain pills this last run but
not much but that's it now
I that's why everything because it's
even being put in the lead now so I went
to The Dispensary
and um I've had so many friends die from
overdosing on fentanyl it's ridiculous
so
I've I've tried I've stayed clear of it
but coming back to sobriety coming back
to
to it's been hard
it's been hard you know when I first
came in I had that seven years I was
ready
however I regret that I don't want to
use but this time it's been so hard like
I wanted you what made you relapse
snack up on me
is the loss of your dad I think no that
that was a factor but I had to it snuck
up on me
somebody was like here are some shrooms
and I went okay you know like it just
snuck up on me I wasn't
you know I wasn't going to
um
I go to meetings you know and I I uh
and I and I and I did things like I
helped others to keep my mind off of my
addiction I did that a lot I started
just getting selfish and I
and I just like lost that you know what
I mean I started working more
I had a pet sitting business and
um I just lost contact and I it just I
swear to God it just circle up on me
you know like
I had these I had the end I had these
three pieces of [__] in my apartment
that were just using drugs and I just
didn't want to be alone
but yeah I I a lot I just lost
everything were you happier during those
seven years clean than you were yeah
previously I was so happy in those seven
years
I mean I traveled
I you know I was I was really I sat
still you know I um
I wasn't so antsy so so people listening
to this would be like well why don't you
just continue with that but I think what
happens sometimes
these people aren't comfortable being
happy
they wanted I wanted an escape from
reality
you know I when life becomes too much I
want to escape reality I want to go down
the rabbit hole of not feeling in drugs
and alcohol help me do that
you know like right last night my
catalytic converter got stolen and I was
like
I want to use really bad right now you
know what I mean in the moment that
because I don't know if I'm gonna get
that be able to get that fixed I have no
money right now you know it's the new
car it's the only thing I have left over
for my sobriety days and I really want
to [__] hit a blunt you know what I
mean like I was like you know I just
don't and it's Thursday it's the small
things in life that are like this which
are inevitable yeah
huh which are inevitable yeah but I want
to use
when those things hit you know what I
mean it's not even so much the bigger
things like my father's death I handle
like a champ it's those things
like breaking a shoe tie you know like
or that
I really wanted to use last night with
my car didn't that happen you know what
I mean and and and and and then even
like the thought of handling that like I
had to call the car people I have to all
that I really like I'm like I don't
wanna [__] deal with it you know what
I mean
and so
yeah it's
I I I had to find myself again because I
used to have a strong sobriety
you know like that wouldn't even phase
me today I feel better you know
so
looking back at your life what do you
wish you had done differently
laughs
the person that gave me the mushrooms
she was my one of my best friends and
we were in sobriety together
and I used to have
um a rule that if you weren't in
sobriety I couldn't well if you weren't
in sobriety I wasn't going to let you
too close you know for my safety
and she came to me and she said uh
where I'd gone out you know I'm using
again and I didn't listen to my I was I
didn't listen to myself and I continue
being friends
she was a factor in my downfall if I had
to do it differently again I would have
said well have a good life
enjoy your using
you know and protected my sobriety but I
didn't do that
so that's what I would that's what I
would do differently you know from now
on I can't hang around people that are
using or drinking
I gotta really
really and then also I have to dive into
the trauma
and I have to I wasn't doing that
the trauma of what exactly
you know
like
the teasing that my cousins did which is
horrible huh which is horrible for a kid
I mean it got to the point where I
couldn't even turn a corner you know I
remember they they had me jump off
of a roof of
a house into a pool
and I was still to this day remember my
side of my face
almost hitting the concrete I remember
the side of my face almost like this
hearing of its passing the concrete
I mean they really made my childhood a
living hell when I stayed over there
and it was because I was different you
know because I had this voice
and I had I was feminine you know what I
mean
and there was other things you know I
had um
I had other things that I had to work
through
but the mushrooms uncovered it I have to
say because I forgot about a lot of
stuff
so and and I had to say the mesh the
mushrooms are a blessing and a curse
because a lot of stuff was uncovered
with the mushrooms that I forgot about
so maybe I mean that maybe it's just
part of my journey
but I don't and The psychosis that came
from it I would never want to deal with
again right how old do you know I am 40
you're 40. yeah so it ain't cute are you
still going to continue with the Miss
Patty Persona I think so
um when I
um
get through this hard time
and I have my life straightened I would
like to pursue acting and go to some
comedy improv classes and on the side I
would like to try to see what I'm see
what it's like to be an actor in this
town like so many
that somebody told me the only time
you're gonna feel peace is if you're
creating
Miss Elliot said that I would buy that
huh I would I'd agree with that yeah so
we're artists you know
as soon as you stop you yeah you'll find
some other distraction and that's
usually a bad one yeah
so the happiest time I ever had is when
you were working on our talk show me and
my track sister need a diamond
and um
so we just had fun and you know it's a
labor of love you know about that you
have this and I just loved it we we
would crack up you know and and then
when we opened up Catalina's first Pride
it was like a dream come true you know
what I mean so I want to go back to it
yeah I do I don't know about drag
but maybe just acting or or that baby
drag I don't know I'm not I just want to
find something creative to do you know
what's your biggest fear now
two elaps
to relapse
and to go into a psychosis that I won't
return from
that's something to be afraid of very
very much
yeah I don't I don't ever want to
experience
The psychosis
and I I just don't want to
lose myself again
what's your relationship like with your
family now
my mom and I have a d a a decent
relationship it's getting better
you know I try to meet her where she's
at
I am surprised by her
she's really come through for me a lot
and um
you know I try to move her out here and
uh
you know
we were like water and oil oil and water
and we're exactly we're very similar and
um
we did not get along even in seven years
it's right I did not get along with her
and I had a lot of resentment against
her
but recently
she really came through for me and I I
really had to say out of love out of
respect comes love because I really I've
always respected her
for for a month for her mom her mother's
skills and
um as a woman
okay
um we respect and love are much more
closely related than than love and sex
or loving yeah
respect is is huge yeah and having
somebody that's really on your side no
matter what how bad no matter how bad
you screw up
who still has your son is like that like
that no matter if I was right or wrong
my dad was like
on my side
and my mom
was always on his side
my mom is a Spanish loyal wife with a
person on the on the lap you know
they were married 43 years my mom and
dad and um
I'm lucky to come from a marriage of
love not a marriage of like they're just
holding on my parents were in love
and so
um
but I I'm I'm just I guess I'm
I'm very surprised at my mother's
loyalty to me
you know do you have siblings I have
step siblings
I have um a sister in Chile and a sister
in Stockholm Sweden who are from your
dad or your previous marriages of my
mother of your mother
um
do you have friends now
I do
that helps yeah I a lot of the boys that
went through my LGBT sober living are my
friends and they're doing well now I
remember one
one friend of his name was Fernando I
just saw him
um and um he could not stay sober to
save his life and now he's getting a
year
and I would always let him return
and um to the silver living I would
catch so much slack for it
and it's a trip he's getting me you're
not it's a trip that he's getting near
and I only have 19 days
but he was so happy to see me
um
and a lot of people are doing well a lot
of people are doing and they're just you
know what when I see them you I would
think
um I saw another friend of mine
I saw two one friend of mine and
I I expect
I guess like I don't know what to expect
when I tell them I have 19 days
but they're happy I'm alive
they're just happy I'm alive even people
that I had problems with
or were catty in the past
they're happy I'm alive I think so many
people have lost people yeah because of
fentanyl but it's [__] Fentanyl you
know what I mean
um
and um I have one friend that I'm
meeting Saturday I believe it is and we
both were going through
our addiction at the same time and we
both are
going to rehab he's in rehab and um
man we just went through it you know and
again just happy each other alive and
it's like it's like a trauma Bond almost
you know like we we've survived drugs
you know what I mean
so yeah
Miss Patty what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
do the work
even if it's uncomfortable
stay present and in the moment
and find ways to be content with what
you have
you know
and stay grateful and humble because
that was the thing when I had the
apartment in Newport
I had my own pet sitting business
you know and it was never enough
you know and that ate me alive
you know
so
had created me content on a daily basis
just to be content you know
so that that's that's what I pray for
finding a creative project that you can
be passionate about is yes there's a key
to that yes to find a creative project
that can pour my soul into I would love
that yeah
excellent all right Miss Patty thank you
so much for coming in sharing your story
yes I wish you lots of luck thank you
thank you very much